in our last episode of bigquery
spotlight we walk through the structure
and components of the bigquery resource
model
in this episode we're drilling in deeper
on tables
covering each of the different table
types and when to use them
stay tuned
[Music]
so what is a table a bigquery table is a
resource
that lives inside of a data set it
contains individual records
organized into rows with each record
composed of columns
or fields that have an enforced data
type
bigquery supports many different data
types including
decimal representations for precision in
financial use cases
geography for geospatial data plus
structs and arrays for complex data oh
and keep an eye out for more data types
that will support
semi-structured data coming soon
aside from simply storing your data
tables can also be used to control
access to information and store metadata
such as descriptions and labels
there are several different types of
tables in bigquery so let's go ahead and
dig deeper
into each one the first table type we'll
talk about is a manage table
managed tables are tables where data is
saved in bigquery's native storage
let's jump into the console and create a
new managed table
when getting started with bigquery you
might already have some data that you
want to load into a table
such as a csv file living on your
computer
here you can specify a local file and
leverage schema auto detect
so that bigquery infers the name and
data type of each column
alternatively you may want to create an
empty table
where new rows will be inserted through
data pipelines
in this case you'll use the create table
statement in a sql query
to create a new managed table with a
specified schema
and a set of configuration options
this is going to be a pretty big table
so let's take it
one step further and include partition
and cluster keys
so that bigquery stores the data in a
way that will make queries much more
performant
another great thing about managed tables
is that you can use
time travel to access data that has been
changed in the past seven days
so no need to panic if you accidentally
erase a row or a table
you can still query data that was
deleted or has expired
now what if your data is already stored
somewhere else
like a data lake located in a cloud
storage bucket
other systems might also be accessing
this data
say spark workflows running on a
dataprop cluster
if you took the approach of replicating
the data in a managed table
you would have two different versions
one stored in cloud storage
and one stored in bigquery which could
lead to mismatching analyses
this situation is a good use case for
our second type of table
external tables give you the ability to
query data that's stored outside of
bigquery
preserving a single source of truth
bigquery currently supports querying
data stored in cloud bigtable
google drive and cloud storage which can
include leveraging
hive based partitioning let's create an
external table that points to a json
file
living in our storage bucket
this time you'll specify that it's an
external table
and also specify the format and file
path for the data
you can now join this data onto other
tables in bigquery
so long as it's stored in the same
region
aside from creating an external table in
bigquery
you can also create a connection which
is more like an external data set
a connection links bigquery to a cloud
sql database
and allows you to create external
queries
an external query executes the query in
cloud sql
and returns results which you can
leverage in bigquery
both connections and external tables are
examples of federation
meaning bigquery will go and fetch the
data from the external source
at the queries runtime this offers a
great approach to ensure
everyone in your organization is working
off of the same data sources
however you should keep in mind that
query performance
probably won't be as high as querying
data in native bigquery storage
so far we've talked about tables stored
inside of bigquery
and tables stored outside of bigquery
but let's imagine that you want to
create an aggregate version
of an existing bigquery table for
example
a sum of sales each day you could
create a whole new manage table using a
sql query
but you would need to re-run that
statement each time the aggregate table
needs to be refreshed
a better option is to use a view
views are virtual tables that are
defined by a sql query
in bigquery you can create a logical
view
a view where the defining query is
simply executed at runtime
or you can create a materialized view
which is recomputed in the background
when the base table changes
materialized views are great for
improving performance
because the results are saved and reused
as opposed to re-running the query each
time you're leveraging the view
and better yet bigquery will actually
re-route queries against your base table
to the materialized view in order to
make things more efficient
however there are some limitations on
the sql you can use
but these are in flux so keep an eye out
on future releases
on the other hand logical views are less
restrictive
in the terms of sql that you can use
logical views are also really useful for
granting users access to results of a
query
even if they don't have access to the
underlying data set
this is known as an authorized view for
more
details check out our previous video
linked below
congrats now you know all the different
table types in bigquery
and some best practices on when to use
them for more guidance on getting
started with bigquery
or digging deeper into bigquery resource
concepts
check out the links below thanks for
joining us today for bigquery spotlight
watch out for the next episode and
remember stay curious
[Music]
you